[MUSIC PLAYING]
When you bake at home,
think about the people
that you are serving food to.
The people that you
love, the people you
want to please with your food.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Perfect.
The first contact you
have with the food
is always a visual contact.
My pastries are
like a silent film.
You have to be seduced by it.
That's amazing.
I'm going to teach
you the building
blocks of pastry, with a
simple recipe make something
beautiful.
You have to learn to
really master a croissant.
I call it the omelet of pastry.
It should feel super
fluffy and light.
I look at this honeycomb.
This air pocket flakes all over.
This is a really
beautiful croissant.
I think it's very important to
have everything in front of you
before you start doing anything.
When you whisk something,
everything is in the wrist.
Draw an eight with your
whisk, and then draw a zero.
You repeat this forever.
[LAUGHS]
Pastry is very precise
and scientific.
You have to measure,
prepare, plan.
Less than three seconds.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Being creative is everything.
Super smooth, shiny.
You can see the glaze
that's been done properly.
When you look into it, you
can see your reflection.
[LAUGHS]
You can be creative as well.
Being creative is also
connecting with people.
Think about who you
are serving food to.
Baking can be daunting.
You should never be intimidated.
Anyone can be a great
baker with a good teacher.
I'm Dominique Ansel, and
this is my MasterClass.